ashley's in tampa florida hey ashley
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you what's up
so i have a question that's at the
intersection of
marriage kids and finances
um i
have considered divorce and um
there's a couple of different factors
for that um
a big one is finances
since we've been married we have been in
debt
uh we i don't know if he was in debt
before i married him but i was in debt i
i wasn't
well i had a small student loan
um that i took care of within the first
few years of our marriage
um anyway we got to about 140
000 of debt mostly on credit cards
and a lot of different factors went into
that
but there was a point i i was just
stressing me out so much
and um you know i did all the zero
percent refinancing and all that
and um anyway so a few years ago i
listened to okay actually i'm sorry
honey i hate to catch you off but you're
going to tell us what you need yes
how can we help so i'm considering
divorce
and i guess i wanted to get your
perspective on the best timing for that
there's not good timing for that that's
a horrible thing to have to go through
darling
so and it's due to disagreements over
money
uh and kids and kids
uh what do you mean about kids having
them or how to treat them or what
yeah i guess bringing them up i'm sorry
i didn't know i was gonna get emotional
it's okay it's fair it's an emotional
thing
yeah and how old are your babies
uh 14 12 and four
okay and so what is he doing about money
that makes you want to end this
so as i said i had started listening to
a few years ago and so i put together a
budget
and i've been just really hammering on
the debt i've got it down to about
60 000 without the mortgage where is he
why is he not helping i have asked him
to help i have had several conversations
with him
did you make did you make all the debt
by yourself
no it's been with the family i think i'm
a big
factor maybe that's what i i haven't
considered that but
uh no it's just
he never said why he won't help
no he wants me to handle it and then be
involved once the debt is handled
why why it's not logical
he's not given a reason he's just
that was the conversation how it ended
up is that
i'll handle the debt and then when it's
done then we'll talk and make plans and
stuff
okay um
well obviously that's not a good plan uh
and
is that is that reason enough to end a
marriage no
uh but is it enough to be upset about
yes and
is it an unreasonable process yes so
uh what i would tell you is this i i
um i think you need someone to guide you
through uh this relationship
and before you just slap your hand on
the table and say that's it i'm done
uh and maybe can guide you through some
tools
conversationally to uh try to draw you
guys
back together and to work together and
so what you need is a good marriage
counseling my guess is mister i'm not
involved it doesn't want to go to
marriage counseling either
but you can go without him but you can
go without him and talk to a marriage
counselor who can
hear your whole story long form and who
can inject
better wisdom than we can here in a
five-minute radio call
because i i'm definitely not going to
tell somebody unless there's uh domestic
violence involved unless you're getting
beat
that your marriage is over on the radio
that would be very unwise of me and very
advised of you to listen to me if i did
do that
but if there's something other than that
you've got some work to do
before you throw down the ultimatum
gauntlet
and sit down with your pastor sit down
with a marriage counselor someone to
guide you through
to where you can say okay i can't stay
anymore
after you've learned how to do this not
from me but i can't stay anymore
unless you're willing to do this with
the kids and this with the money yeah
and whatever this is and you fill in
those blanks and
uh but you've got you've got 15 or 20
years invested in this process
with a 13 year old and so um
you know you want to be very s very wise
and very systematic in how you walk
through this
that way you won't it won't be on you
yeah
and i can hear the stress in her voice
dave and i i want to encourage
everyone who's married out there and if
you're relate you can relate to her
listen to dave advice i mean seek
marriage counseling
even if it's by yourself i can't speak
to much of it because i'm not married
and i've never been in that situation
but we do know that the number one
reason for divorces are finances
and so uh but we could do better at just
getting the council getting the wisdom
before we run
yeah so i mean you'd want to draw out
why you won't get involved and see if we
can solve that
yeah so the other thing we'll do is put
you guys into ramsey plus
into financial peace university again i
don't know if he'll go but we can help
you
through the process and hold on kelly
will pick up and we'll definitely give
you that
as a tool hopefully to save your
marriage